dans cette boutique ronning cyclisme et
outdoor les fêtes de noël se prépare le
vélo reste un des cadeaux les plus
souhaités
ils représentent environ 90% de leur
activité typiquement pour la période de
noël c'est un cadeau qui est assez
plébiscité surtout ils veulent enfoncer
un peu leur première liberté
donc vous avez là des vélos de
différentes marques et en termes de prix
bas on démarre à moins de 200 euros pour
aller sur un 24 pouces à plus de 500
euros le mois de décembre représente
entre 10 à 15 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires
on remarque qu'en décembre on a souvent
affaire à des clients qui cherchent des
produits plaisir donc ça peut être des
montres connecter avec gps des vélos
pour les enfants à retrouver au pied du
sapin de noël et des produits qui sont
innovants notamment liées à la sécurité
en vélo la particularité de cet
éclairage là c'est qu'il fait aussi
office de radars donc c'est un produit
qui va dicter les véhicules à 150 mètres
du cycliste et qui va lui donner la
progression sur un écran soit sur
l'écran qui est fournie ou soit ça va
être connecté directement sur un an
un conteur gps de la même marque ce
produit est sur le marché depuis deux
ans un cadeau pour noël d'une valeur de
139 euros
mais la sécurité n'a pas de prix pour
ses proches